[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and in this video we
will be looking at what Frieza is really
up to in the tournament of power what
aren't his true motivations what will he
ultimately decide to do and what is he
scheming together with frost who is a
member of freezes race but also a
fighter for our rival universe I think
that this is a really interesting topic
and it's something that I've been
wondering for a long time so that's what
we're gonna be looking at in this video
and of course if you have your own
theories about what freeze and frost are
up to let me know down below now here's
what we know so far in episode 95 Frieza
is able to overcome cedras energy of
destruction and the Supreme Kai of
universe 9 tells Sidra that Frieza is
more of a god of destruction than him in
episode 96 we see that Frieza and Frost
decide to make a secret deal to work
together and in episode 99 Frieza says
about Zeno one day I promise I shall
reign over you all of this is obviously
heavy foreshadowing that Frieza is going
to become stronger probably reaching the
power of a god of destruction if not
surpassing it all together and it seems
clear that he is up to something devious
episode 107 of Dragon Ball super bears
the title revenge and the cunning trap
and this is a direct reference to
resurrection F which was a 2015 Dragon
Ball Z film which revolved around Frieza
being resurrected once Dragon Ball super
came out the immense of that film were
incorporated with some changes into the
Dragon Ball super series so the question
is does this F in the title also refer
to Frieza his Frieza getting his revenge
on someone or does this F refer to Frost
from the previews and spoilers for
episodes 107 one way that we have so far
we learned that Frieza will potentially
betray universe 7 and team up with Frost
but we don't know if he's playing a
double game will he really openly betray
universe 7 or will he
simply pretend to do that and then wait
for an opening to take universe six out
of the game we know that Frieza doesn't
want to go back to hell and that he
wants to be resurrected but how will he
try to achieve this will he stick with
universe 7 or will he try to change
sides and fight for universe six in the
hopes of wishing himself back to life
with the super dragon ball in the past
Zeno has been shown to be persuadable
about changing or adjusting the
tournament rules like when he allowed
Master Roshi to use the mokuba in
episode 105 because he thought it was an
interesting ability we know how devious
and manipulative Frieza and frost can be
so what if they try to trick or
manipulate Zeno into changing the rules
again in a way that gives them some sort
of advantage for example if Frieza
really does want to betray universe 7
and switch sides perhaps he will
convince Zeno that allowing anyone who
wants to switch sides to do it would
spice things up and make the tournament
even more fun if Zeno suddenly decided
to allow fighters to switch sides this
will throw the entire tournament into
chaos and I can imagine all of the
different gods of destruction trying to
convince the other fighters from the
other universes to switch sides I can
just imagine - crazy bargaining and deal
making that would be going on there and
I have to admit this would make the
entire tournament a lot more interesting
the other possibility is that Frieza
and Frost might try to convince Zeno to
allow killing in the tournament of power
we know that Frieza wants to kill he was
disappointed when he learned that he
couldn't and he certainly wants revenge
on Goku and Vegeta even if he didn't
switch sides Frieza would love the
opportunity to kill Goku and Vegeta his
main rivals in universe 7 and then
return as the undisputed emperor of the
universe as soon as the tournament is
over this change would also completely
transform the entire tournament and
since we know that the losing universes
are already getting erased it doesn't
seem so far-fetched that Zeno could be
persuaded to allow killing one other
thing to think about is that by trying
to trick Zeno Frieza and Frost might
find themselves in the crosshairs of the
grand priest who seems to have his own
plans for Zeno at any rate I can't wait
to see what
is really up to he was always one of my
favorite villains in the entire
franchise and I would love to hear what
you guys think so let me know down in
the comments we'll freeze that really
betray universe 7 is he going to try to
manipulate Zeno in some way and what
role is Frost going to play in all this
let me know down below if you enjoyed
this type of video and want to see more
Dragon Ball super content here at Anime
uproar be sure to hit that like button
and if you are new to the channel don't
forget to subscribe and click that
notification bell as always thank you so
much for watching and until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]